[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de france24 la
desaparición y asesinato de the bank y
escobar en monterrey nuevo león fue el
detonante de nuevas manifestaciones en
contra de una violencia machista
exacerbada en mexico organizaciones
feministas lideran el reclamo para que
el estado garantice la protección de
mujeres y niñas en un país donde al
menos 10 mujeres son asesinadas al día
el clamor es el mismo de siempre ni una
más veamos la historia
el caso de the bank y escobar ya está en
la lista de investigaciones por
feminicidios de mujeres en méjico la
joven de 18 años hallada sin vida el 21
de abril tras permanecer casi dos
semanas desaparecida en la ciudad de
monterrey fue vista por última vez
bajándose de un taxi en una carretera
aparentemente tras una discusión con el
conductor sus restos fueron encontrados
en el tanque de agua de un motel la
historia que aún no está clara se
convirtió en un doloroso recordatorio de
la brutal violencia que viven las
mujeres en el país
vine porque estoy como todas muy enojada
muy indignada y con mucho miedo de
seguir viviendo en un país en donde pasa
lo que le pasó a de baño en varias
concentraciones miles han salido a las
calles reclamando justicia para ella y
para al menos 327 mujeres desaparecidas
en lo que va de este año según datos
entregados por el propio gobierno y
ojalá la gente se dé cuenta de la
realidad de lo que estamos pasando de la
realidad de los homicidios de la
realidad de cómo se desaparecen y matan
día a día a las personas a las mujeres y
que se unan con nosotros nosotros no
somos las malas ni somos histéricas
somos históricas porque porque estamos
haciendo justicia por las que ya no
están alzando la voz y lo vamos a seguir
haciendo
cuantas veces sea necesario las vallas
protectoras de la fiscalía del estado se
llenaron de fotos de de bani y de
grafitis denunciando la ineficiencia del
estado para proteger la vida y la
dignidad de las mujeres la fiscalía los
jueces la policía todos son una bola de
corrupción
de ineficiencia de insensibilidad no no
están en nuestros zapatos si el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
lamentó el hecho ante la prensa y la
fiscalía de nuevo león se comprometió a
una investigación exhaustiva en el caso
de de baní yo quiero reiterar que la
investigación no ha terminado
estamos en un proceso no hemos concluido
día a día hemos estado
recolectando
datos de prueba
pero ya se han encontrado fallos en las
pesquisas que apenas iniciaron la
fiscalía general del estado destituyó al
fiscal especializado en personas
desaparecidas y el fiscal antisecuestros
quienes encabezaban el caso de la muerte
de la joven de baní escobar por graves
omisiones y errores en la investigación
pero no hay confianza en las autoridades
en un país donde la violencia contra las
mujeres ha aumentado en los últimos años
con un promedio de 10 asesinadas al día
según cifras oficiales mientras tanto
organizaciones feministas y de derechos
humanos exigen que el crimen no quede
impune
las autoridades mexicanas continúan
cometiendo deficiencias que vulneran el
derecho de las mujeres a una vida libre
de violencias la violencia machista es
endémica en américa latina' la región en
general carece de políticas feministas
eficientes
para conversar el sobre la situación de
violencia en méxico y más
específicamente en el estado de nuevo
léon está en ellos hoy angélica orozco
ella es integrante de fuerzas unidas por
nuestros desaparecidos y desaparecidas
en nuevo león angélica gracias y
bienvenida monterrey es el municipio de
nuevo león que más registra
desapariciones de mujeres qué
explicación encuentran ustedes para ese
fenómeno
hola ángel muchas gracias por el espacio
y por permitirnos visibilizar este
terrible delito que continúa el nuevo
león pues desde hace años nosotras como
fuerzas unidas por nuestros
desaparecidos y desaparecidas en nuevo
león tenemos más de 10 años organizadas
y vemos que este delito ha continuado ha
permanecido y no solamente no han
encontrado a las personas que fueron
desaparecidas en años anteriores sino
que continúan desapareciendo nos
actualmente nuevo león tenemos más de
6000 personas desaparecidas donde
alrededor de 1800 son mujeres y somos el
cuarto estado en todo méxico con más
casos reportados de personas
desaparecidas la violencia continúa la
inseguridad continúa y lamentablemente
vemos que siguen las mismas respuestas
por parte de las autoridades
amnistía internacional ha insistido en
que cuando una mujer es reportada como
desaparecida es la debida actuación de
las autoridades la que puede ser
fundamental para encontrarla con vida
pueden las autoridades en este momento
evitar más feminicidios
debe de ver salvo que les hemos exigido
desde ese tiempo deben de tener un
programa de prevención de este delito
del delito de las desapariciones de los
homicidios deben de emprender acciones
contundentes deben de tener un enfoque
de género en las desapariciones de
mujeres el mismo protocolo de búsqueda
menciona en cuando existe la
desaparición de una mujer debe de
presumirse la la posible comisión de un
delito entonces deben de tener este
enfoque diferenciado es un porqué de
género las mismas leyes que ya se han
creado en todo este tiempo los
protocolos se los indican y las
recomendaciones internacionales también
sin embargo lo que se hace normalmente
es culpar a la víctima desaparecida
porque fue irresponsable o porque estaba
tomando tragos o por como yo vestida o
porque fue de fiesta y esto retrasa
muchas veces las investigaciones y aquí
le pregunto tanto en el caso de las
desaparecidas como cuando se investigan
asesinatos de mujeres hay una gran
deficiencia porque las autoridades
siguen sin tratar estos temas con
enfoque de en qué consiste ese enfoque
de género y porque puede marcar toda la
diferencia a la hora de encontrar a una
mujer que desapareció
si como bien lo mencionas desde el
discurso que emiten los titulares de la
fiscalía general de justicia en nuevo
léon de la secretaría de seguridad
pública de la comisión local de búsqueda
y vemos una estigmatización y
revictimización de las víctimas al tener
estos discursos que minimizan este grave
delito minimizan el contexto de
inseguridad en el que vivimos y
optimizan a las personas entonces desde
el discurso ellos deben de emprender
acciones sin tener estos prejuicios para
buscarles y encontrarles tomando las
características relevantes del caso para
poder hacer una correcta investigación
nosotras en algunos casos que ya hemos
denunciado
les hacemos ver que la trata pudiera ser
una línea de investigación sin embargo
ellos los ven como casos aislados aunque
otras denunciamos el año pasado una
crisis de desapariciones de mujeres en
el municipio de sabinas hidalgo nuevo
león donde fueron desaparecidas 11
mujeres de agosto a noviembre
3 fueron localizadas lamentablemente sin
vida y las demás continúan sin ser
encontradas aquí hemos visto
de aspectos que se repiten como la zona
geográfica la edad algunas se conocían y
la fiscalía sigue viéndolo
convirtiéndolos como casos aislados
y no tomando en cuenta estos estos
patrones que se repite y esto nos habla
de un enfoque que definitivamente tiene
que cambiar un ejemplo de esas
deficiencias se ha encontrado
lamentablemente en el caso actual que
tiene las protestas desatadas desde hace
algunas semanas y es el de de baní
escobar que dificultades o que problemas
han encontrado ustedes en esta
investigación que apenas está empezando
pues hemos visto una serie de
deficiencias irregularidades
dentro de la dentro del caso como en el
caso de maría fernanda también que han
denunciado las mismas familias el
retraso en las investigaciones que no
les dieron acceso ni siquiera al
expediente de la familia y una serie de
irregularidades en el sitio lo catearon
bueno lo inspeccionaron porque realmente
luego en una orden de cateo si no fue
una inspección
estuvieron cuatro veces ahí en ese sitio
donde fue encontrada lo cual es
sumamente grave porque llevaron hasta
perros en binomios caninos y no para
poder detectar restos o cuerpos humanos
entonces esto nos habla de que no se
hizo una una investigación exhaustiva en
el sitio también apenas están
descubriendo vídeos del lugar entonces
esto nos habla que no se hizo una
correcta investigación de manera
exhaustiva en esos puntos tan relevantes
porque fue la zona de la desaparición
entonces si es malas prácticas se
repiten en este caso qué tan visible es
tan visible que esperamos de los demás
casos nosotros en todos estos más de 10
años que llevamos organizadas vemos una
serie de irregularidades que se han
seguido repitiendo y este caso lo tembló
dejó en evidencia ante la opinión
pública todas esas deficiencias
continúan también porque nosotros hemos
visto que continúan los mismos
servidores públicos encabezando las
dependencias de seguridad de procuración
de justicia de búsqueda siguen siendo
los mismos funcionarios desde hace más
de 10 años quienes ocupar estos puestos
y por lo tanto dan las mismas respuestas
antes del grave delito no hay una muy
necesaria y muy pedida además de
política pública que sea feminista y que
aboga por las mujeres y otra cosa
angélica para ya ir cerrando este
programa es que no solamente son las
desaparecidas el problema aquí es con
los que se quedan en el mejor de los
casos aparecerán con vida o fallecidas
pero hay cientos de miles en mexico que
a través de los años han desaparecido y
de las no se sabe nada usted que nos
recomienda para protegernos de las
agresiones cuando estamos en ámbitos
públicos y privados
pues bueno efectivamente en todo méxico
todo méxico está en riesgo
ante la la falta de seguridad por parte
de las instituciones entonces pues estar
prevenida siempre es estar alertas
visibilizar está este grave delito eso
nos parece sumamente importante para que
la gente
conozca qué sucede reconozca qué sucede
y por tanto pueda estar alerta eso es
algo muy grave que ha hecho el estado
mexicano minimizar este delito en el
informe reciente de la onu se menciona
que es necesario hablar de esto es
necesario aceptar que sucede para que
podamos prevenirlo entonces creemos que
ese es uno de los primeros pasos que se
deben de hacer el hablar de esto es
reconocerlo para poder enfrentar este
este delito y para eso estamos hoy aquí
gracias a usted angélica orozco
integrante de fuerzas unidas por
nuestros desaparecidos y desaparecidas
de nuevo léon a nuestros televidentes
recuerden que pueden ver este y otro de
ellas hoy en francia 24 punto coma ni
una menos
[Música]